OK, America, here's something you don't run into every day, a six-month pregnant lady sitting on a tractor.
好了，美国，你可不常遇见这种事：一个怀孕六个月的女人坐在拖拉机上。
Do you want me to start it?
你想让我启动它吗？
Sure.
当然。
OK.
好的。
Susie lived on the farm for years before she ever got onto the tractor. Her husband, John, is the farmer in the family. Susie's here in rural Tennessee because of him.
苏西在农场住了好几年，才第一次坐上拖拉机。她丈夫约翰是家里的农民。苏西之所以身处田纳西州的乡村，全是因为他。
I was never like a person who idealized farm life. I didn't grow up on farm, I grew up in the suburbs. We didn't have a garden, like I didn't have any romance about farming. I knew people who grew up on farms and they were just poor. That was my idea of farming, more or less.
我从来不是那种理想化农场生活的人。我不是在农场长大的，我是在郊区长大的。我们没有菜园，我对务农没有任何浪漫的幻想。我认识一些在农场长大的人，他们很穷。这差不多就是我对务农的看法。
She first got on the tractor because she had to, after John had a scare in the spring with a neurologic disorder called Guillain-Barre syndrome. The timing was pretty bad. They'd already done the part of farming where you spend all the money to get the seeds into the ground. And then literally, the day before the first harvest, the day before they were going to take the stuff to market for the first time, when they would first be making money, John went into the hospital.
她第一次坐上拖拉机是因为不得不这么做。那年春天，约翰患上了一种叫格林-巴利综合征的神经系统疾病，着实吓坏了他们。时间点糟透了。他们已经完成了务农中最费钱的部分——把种子种进地里。结果，就在首次收获的前一天，就在他们打算第一次把产品送到市场去赚钱的前一天，约翰住进了医院。
Eventually I was paralyzed, quadriplegic. I couldn't swallow, couldn't walk, talk, couldn't shut my eyes, couldn't sleep. And we had no other help on the farm regularly, so we just decided to write off this year's farming.
最终我瘫痪了，四肢瘫痪。我无法吞咽，无法行走，无法说话，无法闭眼，无法睡觉。而且我们在农场里没有其他长期帮忙的人，所以我们只能决定放弃今年的收成。
At that point, Susie was five-months pregnant, going to the hospital every day, where John needed more and more help. He's fine now, but at the time they were scared. He was losing all neurologic control of all of his muscles and they had no idea how bad it was going to get.
那时，苏西已经怀孕五个月，每天都要去医院，因为约翰需要越来越多的照顾。他现在没事了，但当时他们很害怕。他失去了对全身肌肉的神经控制，他们不知道病情会恶化到什么程度。
Susie was also caring for their four year old daughter, and they didn't have much family nearby to rely on. They'd just moved to the area two years before, didn't know people so well. Didn't belong to a church. They knew the farmers in the farmers market, but didn't really socialize with them. They'd never been at each others' homes. for example. And so they were surprised when the farmers at the farmer's market but up a sign in John's booth at the market, explaining his illness, collecting money for him.
苏西还要照顾他们四岁的女儿，而且附近没有多少亲戚可以依靠。他们两年前才搬到这个地区，对周围的人不太熟。他们没参加教堂。他们认识农夫市场里的其他农户，但并没有真正和他们社交。比如，他们从没去过彼此家里。所以，当市场里的其他农户在约翰的摊位上挂出一块牌子，解释他的病情并为他募捐时，他们感到非常惊讶。
They opened up a fund, which I was-- they said, do you mind if we do that? And at first I just thought, yeah. I said to John or I said to John's sister, does that mean people think we're poor? I felt like a fund? You know, it just felt like well, we kind of need a fund. It's like, all right, right. So I said, OK, fine. So they set up this bank account as the fund and they collected all this money.
他们设立了一个基金，我当时——他们问我，介意我们这样做吗？起初我只是想，嗯。我对约翰或者约翰的姐妹说，那是不是意味着人们觉得我们很穷？我觉得一个基金？你知道，感觉就是，嗯，我们确实需要一个基金。所以我说，好的，没问题。于是他们设立了这个银行账户作为基金，并募集了所有的钱。
Susie and John's next door neighbor came by every day for six weeks and harvested their flowers and sold them from her booth at the market, giving the money to Susie and John.
苏西和约翰的邻居连续六周每天都过来，采摘他们的花，并在她在市场的摊位上出售，把钱交给苏西和约翰。
A customer made two paintings of flowers that Susie and John had grown, and sold the paintings with the money going to Susie  and John.
一位顾客画了两幅苏西和约翰种的花的画，卖掉画作后，将钱给了苏西和约翰。
The women in Susie's book club all wrote checks. Then one day, at the height of a farmer's busiest season, when spending any time away from the farm costs them money, 10 farmers came and spent the day working in John and Susie's fields. Which really touched John.
苏西读书会的女性朋友们都写了支票。然后有一天，在农户最繁忙的季节，当离开农场一整天对他们来说就是经济损失时，10个农户来了，在约翰和苏西的田里工作了一整天。这真的感动了约翰。
They're taking the day off from their own farm. So they're sacrificing their farm to come out here.
他们从自己的农场请了一天假。他们牺牲了自己的农场来这里帮忙。
Meanwhile, at the preschool where Susie and John take their four year old, Hannah, a school which is not a small town farm school, but a school in a regular suburb of Nashville that they drive a half hour to get to, Susie was informed that the next few months of Hannah's tuition had been paid for. And one of the mothers from the preschool called Susie in the first week of all this trouble and said--
与此同时，在苏西和约翰送四岁女儿汉娜去的幼儿园——那不是小镇上的农场学校，而是纳什维尔郊区的一所普通学校，他们开车要半小时才能到——苏西被告知，汉娜接下来几个月的学费已经付清了。在这一连串麻烦发生的第一周，幼儿园的一位妈妈给苏西打了电话，说道——
If you need help with child care, you're going to need help with this. And she said, are you pregnant? Like you can't eat that hospital food. I said, yeah, but I couldn't coordinate. Like my mind wasn't-- I was trying to try to make sure John was getting the right care and make sure-- I was still trying to keep farm things kind of going. So my brain for coordination was just shot. And she said, we're just going to make a plan here about some of this and we'll just run it by you. And I said, that's great.
如果你需要育儿方面的帮助，你得跟我说。她说，你怀孕了吗？你不能只吃医院的饭菜。我说，是啊，但我无法协调。我的脑子不是——我一直在努力确保约翰得到正确的护理，确保——我还在努力维持农场的事情。所以我的大脑协调能力完全崩溃了。她说，我们会在这里安排好这些事，然后告诉你。我说，太棒了。
Next thing Susie knew, they were handing her a schedule of parents who were going to bring food to the hospital every night. And families who would take Hannah after school every day for the next two weeks.
接下来苏西知道的是，他们递给她一张时间表，上面列着每天晚上会送食物到医院的家长，以及接下来两周每天放学后会接走汉娜的家庭。
That, to me, was sort of a really-- I mean, I was surprised how much we needed it. I thought we could just sort of patch it together and I could just come home and we just couldn't do it. We just couldn't do it.
对我来说，那真的——我是说，我很惊讶我们需要这么多帮助。我以为我们能凑合一下，我能回家，但我们真的做不到。我们真的做不到。
It changes things having people reach out to like that. Before John got sick, Susie sometimes still had a little daydream of what her life would have been like if she had moved to a big city, like her college friends did.
当人们那样伸出援手时，一切都改变了。在约翰生病之前，苏西有时还会幻想着如果她像大学朋友一样搬到大城市生活会是什么样子。
She pictured going out to neighborhood restaurants, hanging out with people. But she says this experience made her feel like she had her life in Tennessee, like she could never move.
她设想去附近的餐馆，和朋友们闲逛。但她说，这段经历让她觉得自己在这儿——在田纳西的生活就是她的归宿，她再也不会搬走了。
There's always been a feeling of like, how did I land here exactly? And I feel now like it feels like just where we need to be. I just feel like everybody I've told about it, who live in all the places, or have all the lives that I sometimes think might have been mine in other ways--
一直有一种感觉，就是我到底是怎么落脚在这里的？但现在我觉得，这感觉就像是我们注定该呆的地方。我告诉过所有的人，那些住在世界各地、过着我有时认为可能本该属于我的生活的人——
People in New York and Chicago and Minnesota?
纽约、芝加哥和明尼苏达的人们？
People in big cities or in funky, cool places that I sort of think maybe would have been nice or whatever. They all seemed so shocked that people would surround us and help us this way. And I feel shocked at that. I feel like it doesn't feel easy to come by.
住在大城市或者那些时髦、酷炫地方的人，我有时觉得如果住在那里也许会不错之类的。他们似乎都很震惊，竟然有人会这样围绕着我们、帮助我们。我也对他们的惊讶感到震惊。我觉得这种帮助并不容易得到。
Well, from WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。
Today on our program, "Someone to Watch Over Me." Stories of people stepping in to help other people, whether they're ready for it or not. Act One of our program today, "Doctoring the Doctor," in which a wife cares for her husband who is the worst kind of patient of all. Namely, a physician. Act Two, "The Over-Protective Kind," in which a husband worries about his wife's safety on a very dangerous adventure that she's undertaking to a beach resort. Act Three, "Are You a Man, or Are You a Mouse." Aimee Bender contemplates what to do if your man changes from one to the other, literally. Stay with us.
今天节目的主题是“有人守护我”。讲述人们介入并帮助他人的故事，无论他们是否准备好。今天节目的第一幕，“给医生治病”，讲述了一位妻子照顾身为医生的丈夫，他可是最糟糕的那种病人。第二幕，“过度保护型”，讲述了一位丈夫担心要去度假胜地的妻子在一次危险冒险中的安全。第三幕，“你是男人还是胆小鬼”。艾米·本德思考如果你的男人真的从一种变成了另一种，该怎么办。请继续收听。
Act One, "Doctoring the Doctor." Douglas Forde spent his life taking care of others, as a physician in Los Angeles. But in 2003, he had some strokes and was diagnosed with a kind of dementia, something called multi-infarct dementia. It's related to Alzheimer's. Douglas' wife, Jo Giese, is a radio journalist, usually for the radio program Marketplace. And she made dozens of hours of tapes over the course of eight months when she was caring for him and had people in and out of the house taking care of him.
第一幕，“给医生治病”。道格拉斯·福德一生都在照顾别人，他是一名洛杉矶的医生。但在2003年，他中风了几次，被诊断出患有一种痴呆症，称为多梗死性痴呆。它与阿尔茨海默症有关。道格拉斯的妻子乔·吉斯是一位广播记者，通常为广播节目《市场》工作。在他患病的八个月里，当她照顾他并让人们进进出出照顾他时，她录下了几十个小时的磁带。
The kind of situation that Douglas got into at this point in his life is the kind of thing that happens all the time now, but didn't just 25 or 30 years ago. What's happened is that we've gotten so good at keeping people alive for years that they survive to create a whole community, an economy, a family of people who care for them. Douglas and Jo's house turned into a kind of mini hospital, of people caring for Douglas. Here's Jo's story.
道格拉斯人生中遇到的这种情况，是现在经常发生的事情，但在25或30年前却不会发生。发生的变化是，我们已经能够让人们存活多年，以至于他们活了下来，并创造了一个完整的社区、经济体系和一个照顾他们的家庭。道格拉斯和乔的家变成了一个迷你医院，充满了照顾道格拉斯的人。这是乔的故事。
In January 2003, I found my husband asleep in a pool of blood, the back of his head sliced open from a fall on the bathroom floor. He was hospitalized and his doctor thought he might die.
2003年1月，我发现我丈夫倒在血泊中，后脑勺因为摔倒在浴室地板上被割开了。他住院了，医生认为他可能会死。
Six months later he had a massive stroke that left him unable to talk, walk, write. He was incontinent. Again, his doctor thought he might die. It's after this second false alarm with death, and after three and a half years of Douglas being ill, three and a half years of caring for him, not sure what else to do with myself, that I grabbed my tape recorder. I start recording on Father's Day.
六个月后，他严重中风，导致无法说话、行走、写作。他大小便失禁。医生再次认为他可能会死。在第二次虚惊一场后，在道格拉斯患病三年半、我照顾他三年半、不知道自己还能做什么之后，我拿起了录音机。我从父亲节开始录音。
Is there anything else we need to put on the tape?
磁带上还有什么需要录的吗？
Padrina's 35 and she's from Belize. She has the sturdy body of a weightlifter, which is important because if Douglas falls again I need someone who can lift him. Douglas is so wobbly that for his safety he's confined to the first floor of our two-story house. In fact, he even sleeps downstairs in a hospital bed in the living room. It's just two weeks since his massive stroke. Now he's using a wheelchair, sometimes a walker.
帕德丽娜35岁，来自伯利兹。她有举重运动员般结实的体格，这很重要，因为如果道格拉斯再次摔倒，我需要一个能抱得动他的人。道格拉斯站立不稳，为了安全起见，他被限制在我们两层楼房子的第一层。事实上，他甚至睡在客厅的医用病床上。他严重中风才过去两周。现在他用轮椅，有时用助行器。
We're going to close this a little bit. Padrina, why don't you help Douglas come in.
我们要把它关上一点。帕德丽娜，你为什么不帮道格拉斯进来呢。
Padrina's not a nurse. She has no professional or medical training. During the week she works at a print shop printing up business cards. She's a caregiver. Its work usually done by new immigrants. I've had over a dozen of them living with us 24 hours a day for the past six months. The caregivers bathe Douglas, trim his nails, shave him, cook for him, dress him. In those long periods when there's nothing to do for Douglas, they also help around the house. They do some light housekeeping. To help Douglas remember Padrina's name, I've written it on all the white boards I've placed around the house since he's been sick. I also made her a name tag.
帕德丽娜不是护士。她没有任何专业或医学培训。工作日她在印刷店印名片。她是一名护理员。这项工作通常由新移民来做。过去六个月里，有十几个人和我们住在一起，全天候照顾他。护理员给道格拉斯洗澡、剪指甲、刮胡子、做饭、穿衣。在照顾道格拉斯的空档期，她们也会帮忙做家务。她们做一些轻便的家务。为了帮道格拉斯记住帕德丽娜的名字，我把它写在我放在屋子各处的白板上。我还给她做了个名牌。
And we'll put him over there on that side and we'll just do it buffet style.
我们就把它放在那边，大家自助取餐。
In all the pre-party chaos, none of us notice that Douglas is no longer in the living room in his wheelchair. We look for him everywhere. Out on the patio, on the deck. I find him at the top of the stairs clinging to the banister for dear life.
在派对前的混乱中，我们谁也没注意到道格拉斯已经不在轮椅上了。我们到处找他。在露台上，在甲板上。我发现他在楼梯顶部，紧紧抓着扶手，拼命保命。
What happened? How did you happen to go upstairs?
发生了什么？你怎么会跑到楼上来？
I just thought I'd go upstairs.
我只是想上楼来看看。
He doesn't remember that he hasn't been upstairs in weeks.
他不记得他已经几周没上过楼了。
You don't really have the strength to go upstairs anymore.
你真的没有力气再上楼了。
Well, I've been doing it for 84 years.
嗯，我这84年都是这么过来的。
Yeah, but we're in a different condition in your life right now.
是啊，但你现在的情况不一样了。
Were you just going to rest here a moment?
你只是想在这儿休息一会儿吗？
Yeah.
是的。
I get him a chair. While he's catching his breath I find Padrina.
我给他拿了把椅子。当他喘气时，我找到了帕德丽娜。
Padrina, come here a second. If I ever ask you to do something like to back him downstairs because people are coming, your main job is to just keep your eyes on Douglas. What happened?
帕德丽娜，过来一下。如果我再让你做点什么，比如因为有人要来而把他带下楼，你的主要任务就是盯着道格拉斯。刚才发生了什么？
Exactly. My job is a nurse, not nurse slash maid.
确实。我的工作是护士，不是护士兼保姆。
OK, but Shoni does housework and she keeps an eye on him. But we've had three examples of this now. This can't go on.
好吧，但是肖妮做家务时也会盯着他。但现在我们已经有三个这样的例子了。这不能再继续下去了。
It's scary. I guess he's not supposed to stay by himself.
真吓人。我想他不应该独自呆着。
Well, he's never by himself.
嗯，他从来没独自呆着。
Yes, of course, never. Even when I use the restroom, I keep a crack on the door. I use it real quick and I keep peeking on him. It takes one second. That's all it took.
是的，当然，从来没有。即使我去洗手间，我也留着门缝。我快速解决然后一直偷看他。只需要一秒钟。就这一秒钟。
OK. So in the future we'll just keep an eye on him a little bit more.
好吧。所以以后我们要再多看他一眼。
Exactly.
没错。
OK, well, I'm going to go downstairs and make the lemonade for the party. You're going to stay up here and watch over his shoulder.
好，我要下楼去为派对做柠檬水。你留在这儿看好他。
OK.
好。
It scares me whenever a caregiver isn't paying attention. I already experienced the shock of finding Douglas once in a pool of blood, I couldn't bear to find him at the bottom of the stairs with a broken neck.
每当护理员不注意时，我都会感到害怕。我已经经历过一次发现道格拉斯倒在血泊中的冲击，我无法承受再发现他摔在楼梯下颈部骨折的样子。
With everything else going on, I'm now managing all these people in my own home. We have two shifts of live-in caregivers. One's Monday to Thursday and the other's Thursday to Sunday. There are six different caregivers rotating in and out, and that doesn't include the visiting nurses and a physical therapist.
随着其他事情的发生，我现在还要管理家里的这群人。我们有两班住家护理员。一班从周一到周四，另一班从周四到周日。有六个不同的护理员轮流进出，这还不包括上门护士和理疗师。
Good morning, did you get my message?
早上好，你收到我的信息了吗？
Yeah, this I did. This is Shoni. She's 53 years old and from the Philippines. She works the Monday to Thursday shift. Shoni's been with us a month. She's been doing this work forever. She's seen a lot of her clients die. Whenever this happens, she flies back home to the Philippines for a couple of weeks to recover.
是的，收到了。这是肖妮。她53岁，来自菲律宾。她负责周一到周四的班次。肖妮在我们这儿工作一个月了。她做这行很久了。她亲眼看着很多客户去世。每当这时，她就会飞回菲律宾休息几周恢复状态。
Good morning.
早上好。
Good morning, Douglas.
早上好，道格拉斯。
How are you?
你好吗？
Fine. I'm sorry I am late a little bit. It's the traffic.
很好。抱歉我迟到了一点。交通太堵了。
I understand the traffic's bad.
我理解，交通很糟糕。
It's bumper to bumper.
车挨着车，动弹不得。
Then there's Evelyn, a visiting nurse from St. John's Hospital. She's kind of seen it all. We enjoy each other. We call each other by our nicknames. She calls me Josie, I call her Evie. On days when Evie isn't making house calls, another nurse, Amanda, stops by. Amanda's style is way too perky for me.
还有伊芙琳，来自圣约翰医院的上门护士。她什么都见过了。我们相处得很好。我们互称昵称。她叫我乔西，我叫她伊薇。在伊薇不来出诊的日子里，另一位护士阿曼达会过来。阿曼达的风格对我来说太欢快了。
OK, I'm going to listen to your heart, and your lungs, and your tummy, and check your blood pressure. And then we'll take you blood and run it to the lab.
好了，我要听一下你的心脏、肺部和肚子，检查一下血压。然后我们要抽血送去实验室。
I cringe when she tells my husband that she's going to look at his tummy. The thing that kills me though, is that if Douglas were his old self, he would too. As a physician, he practiced medicine with a certain elegance. Never in a million years would he have spoken baby talk to a patient.
当她告诉我丈夫她要检查他的“肚子”时，我感到一阵畏缩。让我最受不了的是，如果道格拉斯还是以前的他，他也会一样的。身为一名医生，他行医时有一种优雅感。他绝不会对病人说婴儿语的。
Give me a smile. Good.
笑一个。很好。
And then there's Shirley. She's a weekend substitute. She's from Little Rock, Arkansas. She's 61, stylish, and she laughs easily.
还有雪莉。她是周末的替班。她来自阿肯色州小石城。她61岁，时尚，爱笑。
There's also Don, the physical therapist. He comes in three times a week.
还有唐，理疗师。他一周来三次。
And then we have our unofficial maintenance crew. Each time Douglas's condition changes, Brad comes by to install more handrails and grab bars in the house. Bill comes to clean the carpet. He hasn't been here since Douglas fell in January. There's still some blood from that accident to cleanup.
我们还有非正式的维修团队。每当道格拉斯的病情有变化，布拉德就会过来安装更多的扶手和抓杆。比尔负责清理地毯。自从一月份道格拉斯摔倒后他就没来过。那次事故的血迹还没完全清理干净。
Sorry to be so nosy. I'm just curious, what do the doctors have to say about him? My dad passed away and he lived in the living room for a year, so I just know that's another step in the progression of downwardness. Sorry to say.
抱歉我太爱打听了。我只是好奇，医生对他怎么说？我父亲去世时，他在客厅里住了一年，所以我知道那是病情恶化的又一个阶段。很抱歉这么说。
Having so many people coming in and out of the house, sometimes I feel like I'm getting to know way too many people way too well. At this point, there's not much the caregivers and I don't know about each other.
屋子里这么多人进进出出，有时我觉得我认识的人太多了，太熟了。到了现在，护理员们和我之间几乎没有秘密。
Take Shoni. At night, she wears a red nightie, and every Thursday she rolls her short black hair in pink rollers.
比如肖妮。晚上她穿着红色睡裙，每周四她用粉色发卷卷起短短的黑发。
Shirley spends her off hours at Hollywood Park, the race track, betting on the horses.
雪莉在休息时间去好莱坞公园赛马场赌马。
And Padrina never misses a Lakers game on TV. In turn, they probably know I'm drinking too much. I need this crowd of people to help me run this mini hospital. Except after six months, I'm fed up with never having any privacy. So I just made a sign from my bedroom door. No entrance. Stay out. Except nobody's paying any attention to my sign. They still waltz right in on me. I'll be sitting on the toilet and there they are.
帕德丽娜从不错过电视上的湖人队比赛。反过来，她们可能也知道我酒喝得太多了。我需要这群人帮我经营这家迷你医院。只是过了六个月，我受够了永远没有隐私。所以我给卧室门做了个牌子。禁止进入。离远点。结果没人理我的牌子。她们还是直接闯进来。我就坐在马桶上，她们就在那儿。
I've always thought of myself as a go with the flow person, someone with a little grace under pressure. But after months of caregivers living in my home, drinking my coffee out of my cups, packing my refrigerator with their buns and noodles, I have a short fuse.
我一直认为自己是一个随遇而安的人，一个在压力下保持优雅的人。但在护理员住在家里、用我的杯子喝我的咖啡、把她们的面包和面条塞满我的冰箱几个月后，我的忍耐力变得很差。
But I can't blow up at them because then they'll walk off the job. So I suck it up.
但我不能对她们发火，否则她们就会辞职走人。所以我只能忍着。
Meanwhile, all the simple comforts of marriage are gone. Douglas and I no longer share a bed, and it's Shoni, not me, who tucks my husband in for the night.
与此同时，婚姻中所有简单的慰藉都消失了。道格拉斯和我不再同床共枕，晚上帮我丈夫掖好被子的是肖妮，而不是我。
Okie dokie. While you are sitting, I gave you your medication, OK?
好了，你坐着的时候，我给你喂药，好吗？
OK.
好。
Got it?
明白了吗？
Yeah, I got it.
嗯，我明白了。
Between the medications and the dementia, Douglas's whole personality has changed. He's pulling in to himself. He can't stand it when I touch him. But I still reach out, still try to connect with this man who was once the big love of my life.
在药物和痴呆症的双重作用下，道格拉斯的整个性格都变了。他变得封闭自己。他受不了我碰他。但我还是试图伸出手，试图与这个曾经是我一生挚爱的男人建立联系。
OK, I'm going to go upstairs and take a bath. Shoni will be here.
好了，我要上楼洗个澡。肖妮会在这儿。
Shoni will be here.
肖妮会在这儿。
Would you like me to stay here with you a little bit?
你想让我留在这儿陪你一会儿吗？
What I want him to say is yes. I want to sit by him as long as I can.
我希望他回答的是“是”。我想尽可能长时间地陪在他身边。
No, Jo, don't. Don't bother. I know you're going to have a good bath.
不，乔，别。别麻烦了。我知道你要去洗个好澡。
That's not the point, Doogle. Would you like me to sit here with you a little bit? Would that be a comfort to you?
重点不是这个，道格。你想让我坐在这儿陪你一会儿吗？这对你来说是一种安慰吗？
OK. You can do it, Jo.
好吧。你可以留下来，乔。
Because sometimes it's confusing. I don't know if you are more comfortable just by yourself resting or if it's more of a comfort if I'm here.
因为有时很困惑。我不知道你是独自休息更舒服，还是我在场更让你感到安慰。
Well, as a matter of fact, once I receive a notice that I'm going to go to sleep, I'm going to go to sleep. Do you follow that?
事实上，一旦我收到通知说我要去睡觉，我就会去睡觉。你明白吗？
Yeah.
明白。
I like to go to sleep.
我喜欢睡觉。
OK.
好吧。
Do you follow that?
你明白吗？
Yeah. Good night Doogle.
明白。晚安，道格。
Good night.
晚安。
Marooned upstairs in my bedroom I lie awake and listen to Douglas breathing on the monitor. Sleep is impossible, so most nights I wander back downstairs and look for Shoni. The rooms are dark. I usually find her in the kitchen watching TV. Then I pour myself another glass of wine or two, or three. Shoni usually has tea. We talk about her son, her new grandchild, how much we both like to dance.
我被困在楼上的卧室里，躺在床上醒着，听着监视器里道格拉斯的呼吸声。睡眠是不可能的，所以大多数晚上我都会回到楼下寻找肖妮。房间里漆黑一片。我通常会在厨房里找到她看电视。然后我会给自己再倒上一两杯，或者三杯酒。肖妮通常喝茶。我们谈论她的儿子、她的新孙子，以及我们俩有多喜欢跳舞。
One night in July she tells me she's worried that when Douglas has another stroke the two of us won't be able to lift him. Recently he slid off the toilet and we had to call the fire department to pick him up from the bathroom floor. So far I've had no luck finding a male caregiver, or at least a woman who's Douglas's size. And I just let Padrina go.
七月的一个晚上，她告诉我她很担心，当道格拉斯再次中风时，我们俩可能抬不动他。最近他从马桶上滑下来，我们不得不叫消防队把他从浴室地板上救起来。到目前为止，我还没能找到男护理员，或者至少是个体型跟道格拉斯相当的女性。而我刚辞退了帕德丽娜。
It takes weeks to find someone to replace her and during that time I care for him alone three days a week. I hate some parts of the job and I can tell that Douglas hates me doing them too. When I help him with his personal hygiene he gets this pained look on his face.
花了几周才找到顶替她的人，在那段时间里，我每周有三天独自照顾他。我讨厌这份工作中的某些部分，我也能看出道格拉斯讨厌我做这些事。当我帮他处理个人卫生时，他脸上总是露出痛苦的表情。
One day I'm watching Shoni give Douglas a sponge bath. He's naked on the bed except for one strategically placed towel. And she's scrubbing him with a white terry cloth wash cloth when he turns to me and says--
有一天，我看着肖妮给道格拉斯擦澡。他赤身裸体躺在床上，只有一条精心放置的毛巾遮挡。当她用白色毛巾擦洗他时，他转过头对我说——
I would just assume that you didn't watch all of this.
我倒希望你不要看着这一切。
You don't want me to watch?
你不想让我看着？
No, I don't.
不，我不想。
OK, I'll go away.
好吧，我走。
How would you like it, he asks, if I watched you?
他问，如果我看着你，你会怎么想？
It's taken a few weeks, but I've just found a new weekend caregiver. Vicky's from Bulgaria. She's 27. And like most caregivers, she's perfectly qualified for some other line of work.
花了几个星期，我终于找到了一个新的周末护理员。维琪来自保加利亚。她27岁。和大多数护理员一样，她完全有资格从事其他职业。
I had my master degree in economics. My specialties marketing and trading.
我拿到了经济学硕士学位。我的专业是贸易和市场。
Vicky came to the US less than a year ago with her boyfriend, who's trying to get permanent legal residency. She wears green Spandex bicycle pants. She has a beautiful smile. We can use some light an laughter in this house.
维琪不到一年前来到美国，带着她的男朋友，他正在申请永久居留权。她穿着绿色的紧身自行车裤。她有美丽的笑容。这个家里确实需要一些轻松和笑声。
So Douglas, this is Vicky.
那么道格拉斯，这是维琪。
Hello.
你好。
Hi Vicky.
你好，维琪。
Good morning, how are you?
早上好，你怎么样？
I'm well. How are you?
我很好。你呢？
Fine, thank you.
很好，谢谢。
Vicky has an easy rapport with Doogle and he's charmed by her.
维琪和道格拉斯相处融洽，他被她吸引了。
One morning I walk into the kitchen to find her teaching him the Bulgarian word for French toast.
一天早上我走进厨房，发现她正在教他法式吐司的保加利亚语单词。
So, how are you doing this morning, Doogle?
那么，道格，今天早上你感觉怎么样？
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
[听不清]。
You went upstairs, you had a shower, you've read some of the newspaper.
你上过楼，洗过澡，读过一些报纸了。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
[听不清]。
Come on, Douglas.
得了吧，道格拉斯。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE]. What do you want?
[听不清]。你想要什么？
I'm just asking you how you're feeling this morning?
我只是问你今天早上感觉如何？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
[UNINTELLIGIBLE].
[听不清]。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
Why are the two of you laughing?
你们俩为什么笑？
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
OK, what are your plans for the day? You guys just going to sit around and laugh?
好了，你们今天打算做什么？你们就打算坐在这儿笑吗？
I'm pleased someone unleashes the laughter in Doogle. But for me, I'm the one who's holding everything together. It feels like I haven't laughed in a year. I wake up angry, I go to bed angry.
很高兴有人能引出道格的笑声。但对我来说，我是那个支撑这一切的人。感觉我已经一年没笑过了。我醒来时很生气，睡觉时也很生气。
As you can imagine, money is hemorrhaging out of our bank account. I'm spending over $1,000 a week on caregivers. I've heard about people who end up selling their houses to finance this kind of care. Since Douglas doesn't drive anymore, a few weeks ago we talked about selling his car. At the time, he thought it was a good idea.
可以想象，金钱正从我们的银行账户里大量流失。我每周要花一千多美元请护理员。我听说过有人最终为了支付这种护理费用而卖掉房子。因为道格拉斯不再开车了，几周前我们谈到卖掉他的车。当时，他觉得这是个好主意。
Today, as I'm leaving to show his car to a possible buyer, I remind him about our decision. That turns out to be a big, fat mistake.
今天，当我正要出门把车展示给潜在买家时，我提醒他我们的决定。结果证明那是一个大错特错。
One of the errands I'm doing this morning is I'm taking your car to the Pacific Palisades. Don, the physical therapist, has a client there who might want to buy it.
我今天早上要办的事之一是把你的车开到太平洋帕利塞德。理疗师唐在那儿有个客户，可能想买。
Well, I would really prefer because I'm ready now actually, I would really prefer not selling it and keeping it.
嗯，我实际上更倾向于——因为我现在准备好了——我更倾向于不卖掉它，而是把它留着。
Why would you want to keep it?
你为什么想把它留着？
To drive it.
为了开车。
Who drive it?
谁开车？
Me drive it.
我开车。
You know you don't have a driver's license? You surrendered your driver's license after you had that stroke in January.
你知道你没有驾照吗？你在一月份中风后已经交出了驾照。
I really hate it when you refer to that little episode that I had as a stroke. A stroke is not a stroke. A stroke is not what you're talking about. A stroke is where you can't get out of bed because your whole left side is useless.
我真的很讨厌你把那次小意外称为中风。中风不是中风。中风不是你说的那个意思。中风是指你连床都下不了，因为你的整个左侧都废了。
That's true, of course. But what he's forgetting is that happened to him. He really did have a stroke. A massive one.
那当然是真的。但他忘记的是，那确实发生在他身上。他确实中风了。严重的。
You want to talk to your friends about it, you can refer to it as what it was. It was a TIA, a ischemic attack. That's a spasm. A stroke is a clot. You need to go to medical school in order to learn what a stroke is.
如果你想跟你的朋友谈论这件事，你可以把它称为它本来的名字。那是短暂性脑缺血发作（TIA）。那是痉挛。中风是有血栓。你需要去医学院才能学会什么是中风。
OK.
好的。
I really mean that.
我是真心的。
Douglas and I fell in love on our third date. For 17 years it was the easiest relationship either of us ever knew. To turn away from your beloved, to waste a single day in anger, that's the luxury of the young. We knew life was too short.
道格拉斯和我在第三次约会时就坠入爱河。17年来，这是我们俩经历过的最轻松的关系。拒绝你的挚爱，在愤怒中浪费一天，那是年轻人的奢侈。我们知道生命太短暂了。
When he was well, Douglas was an extraordinary listener. Now there's no listening.
他健康时，道格拉斯是个出色的倾听者。现在，没有人倾听了。
During these four months, she has really not felt well, but has difficulty in describing it.
在这四个月里，她确实感觉不舒服，但难以描述这种感觉。
Just the other day, I found his old dictaphone, the one he used when he was practicing medicine. And in between notes for patients' charts, he accidentally recorded a phone call he made to me. It begins with a sentence he'd never say today.
就在前几天，我找到了他旧的口述录音机，那个他行医时用的。在病人病历的笔记之间，他意外录下了一个给我打的电话。开头的那句话，他今天绝不会再说。
Hello, I was just phoning you to see how you are. OK, that's what I thought. So I just going to say hello and I will probably be home about 2:30, 3 o'clock. Yeah, what time do you meet him? Well, I'll come over to the house first. Yeah. All right, bye.
你好，我只是打电话来看看你怎么样。好了，我想也是。所以我只是想说声你好，我大概两点半到三点会到家。是的，你几点见他？嗯，我会先到家。好的。行，再见。
It's the most ordinary kind of phone call in the world. Two people checking in. And today, even though he's the one with that thousand mile blank stare, and he's the one losing his memory, it's like I'm losing mine too. It's hard to get up the habit of talking to Douglas about every little thing. I keep forgetting that an easy husband-wife chat is no longer possible.
那是世界上最普通不过的电话。两个人相互确认情况。而今天，尽管他有着那种空洞的眼神，尽管他在失去记忆，但感觉就像我也在失去我的记忆一样。很难养成那种和道格拉斯谈论每一件小事的习惯。我总是忘记那种轻松的夫妻聊天已经不再可能了。
How are you feeling about the caregivers who are here in the house. Vicky and Shoni?
你觉得家里的护理员怎么样？维琪和肖妮？
I think get them out. I don't like having people around the house.
我想让她们走。我不喜欢家里有人。
But there is a need for them.
但她们是有必要的。
In what way is there a need for daily nursing? I don't need people here all the time. I notice that when people are here all the time, you're not here. It's as though you're replacing, you're being replaced.
每天护理有什么必要？我不需要人一直在这里。我注意到当人们总是在这里时，你就不在了。就好像你在被取代，你正在被取代。
Well, I agree with you. It's a change.
嗯，我同意你的看法。这是一个改变。
Like yesterday, I was really tired of having people around.
比如昨天，我真的厌倦了家里有人。
See, what's difficult for you to understand is that we are so different.
看，你很难理解的是，我们是如此不同。
You don't need a host of friends coming in?
你不需要一群朋友进进出出？
I don't need anybody except you.
除了你，我不需要任何人。
Hearing this gives me a chill. His whole world is now me. Douglas's life has gotten so small, it's confined to the living room, dining room, kitchen, powder room, the deck. But my life also has a short tether. If I go more than 12 miles from the house I get physically nauseous. I never thought that I'd have anything in common with Nancy Reagan, but when I read that when Ronnie was still alive Nancy didn't go any further than five minutes from their home, in a weird way I felt close to her.
听到这话让我感到一阵寒意。他的整个世界现在就是我。道格拉斯的生活变得如此狭小，仅限于客厅、餐厅、厨房、卫生间、甲板。但我的生活也有很短的羁绊。如果我离开家超过12英里，我就会产生生理性的恶心。我从没想过我会和南希·里根有什么共同之处，但当我读到罗尼活着的时候，南希从不离家超过五分钟，我有一种奇怪的感觉，觉得自己和她很亲近。
It's the end of August. I don't know how much longer I can keep this up. Nine months ago Douglas's doctor urged me to consider a nursing home. But years before that Douglas filled out a medical directive, a standard form with check boxes we got at the stationery store. He marked each box carefully: no life support, must be able to care for himself, communicate meaningfully with others. And then at the bottom of the page in his beautiful, old-fashioned handwriting he added, don't want to go to a rest home. Period. Just want to be at home. Period.
已经是八月底了。我不知道我还能坚持多久。九个月前，道格拉斯的医生敦促我考虑养老院。但几年前，道格拉斯填写了一份医疗指示，那是我们在文具店买的标准复选框表格。他仔细地勾选了每一项：无生命维持系统，必须能自理，能与他人进行有意义的沟通。然后在页面底部，用他那漂亮、老派的笔迹加了一句：不去养老院。句号。只想在家里。句号。
One day at his doctor's office while Douglas sits out in the waiting room with Vicky, I talk about this with Arman, his doctor.
有一天在他医生的办公室里，当道格拉斯和维琪在候诊室坐着时，我和他的医生阿曼谈到了这件事。
So, how long does this go on for. I mean, how do people hang in? I mean, I'm really serious.
所以，这种情况会持续多久。我是说，人们怎么支撑下去？我是说，我真的很严肃。
Very tough. It could go on for 5 years, 10 years, 15 years.
非常艰难。这可能会持续5年、10年、15年。
We would be totally out of money by then.
到那时我们就彻底没钱了。
Well, these things can go-- have a life of their own. As long as he eats and has a good appetite and he's cared for, he could do fine.
嗯，这些事情可能会有自己的轨迹。只要他能进食、胃口好，且得到照顾，他就能过得不错。
Could he get a full-blown Alzheimer's where he doesn't recognize me, doesn't recognize the dog?
他会患上严重的阿尔茨海默症，以至于不认识我，不认识那只狗吗？
Could he get a full-blown dementia that he can do this? The answer is, it's possible. It's highly probable I think in this case.
他会患上严重的痴呆症吗？答案是，有可能。我认为在这种情况下非常有可能。
With medication, you're slowing the pace of the deterioration.
通过药物治疗，你可以减缓恶化的速度。
In other words, the better we care for him, the longer he'll survive. And the more likely he'll live to the point where he doesn't even recognize me.
换句话说，我们照顾得越好，他活得就越久。他活到连我都不认识的地步的可能性也就越大。
Not long after that appointment, Vicky, the one taught Douglas the Bulgarian word for French toast, quits. The hours are too hard for her, she says. And she has a four month old baby.
在那次预约之后不久，教道格拉斯说法式吐司保加利亚语的维琪辞职了。她说工作时间太辛苦了，而且她有个四个月大的婴儿。
I call an agency I used once and explained that I need an older person, strong enough to lift my husband, and experienced enough so that when things get worse, they can point the way and tell me what to do.
我打电话给一家我曾经用过的中介，解释说我需要一个年长、强壮到能抱起我丈夫，且经验丰富的人，这样当情况恶化时，他们可以指导我该做什么。
I end up with Jenny, the youngest, smallest, most inexperienced caregiver of all the 17 people I've hired. She's 23, barely 5 feet tall, has been in the US only 4 months. She's never seen anyone die. She turns out to be perfect for the job.
我最后雇用了珍妮，她是我雇过的17个人里最年轻、最娇小、经验最少的人。她23岁，不到五英尺高，在美国才待了4个月。她从没见过任何人去世。事实证明，她非常适合这份工作。
Douglas continues to decline. By Christmas Eve he's able to sit at the table, but that takes all his energy. He doesn't talk. He just stares. In January, no matter how hot I make the house, Douglas can't get warm. Finally, he slips into a coma and dies February 1 at home of an infection. I just left the room for a second when it happened.
道格拉斯的病情持续恶化。到了平安夜，他能坐在桌边，但这耗尽了他所有的力气。他不说话，只是盯着看。一月份，无论我把屋子弄得有多热，道格拉斯都无法变暖。最后，他陷入昏迷，并于2月1日在家里死于感染。事发时我刚好离开了房间一会儿。
Jenny, his final caregiver, is with him when he takes his last breath. I speak with her a month after he died.
珍妮，他最后的护理员，在他咽下最后一口气时在他身边。在他去世一个月后，我和她谈了谈。
Before he took his last breath, his breathing is harder and closer. But then, I said, he's not going to die at this moment. So I just walk to the window. And then in a few minutes I just heard one last breath. It's like [GASPING SOUND]. I said, oh, he's gone. Then I called you. I can't forget that.
在他咽下最后一口气之前，他的呼吸变得困难且沉重。但我说，他现在不会死的。于是我走到窗边。几分钟后，我听到最后一声呼吸。就像[喘气声]。我说，哦，他走了。然后我给你打了电话。我忘不掉。
You cannot?
你忘不掉吗？
Yeah, I cannot.
是的，忘不掉。
Well, what's interesting to me about this process is since you were with him when he took his last breath, and you were with us, I don't ever want to lose contact with you. You are part of the family.
嗯，关于这个过程，让我感兴趣的是，既然你在他咽下最后一口气时陪着他，而且你一直陪着我们，我永远不想和你失去联系。你是我们家庭的一部分。
What can I say?
我能说什么呢？
So we've become family, Jenny.
所以我们成了一家人，珍妮。
Yeah. I feel that I am the member of your family too.
是的。我觉得我也是你家的一员了。
It's weird, but I miss all the commotion. I miss everything and everyone. I miss the life and death urgency. After Douglas died and everyone cleared out of the house, it was so silent.
这很奇怪，但我怀念所有的喧嚣。我怀念一切和每一个人。我怀念那种生与死的紧迫感。在道格拉斯去世、所有人都搬出房子后，一切都太安静了。
It wasn't just that he was gone, everything was gone. The people, the adjustable bed, the medicines, my mini hospital shut down. I suddenly had nothing to do. I was in shock. So I called Jenny and asked her to come stay with me for a few days.
不仅仅是因为他走了，一切都消失了。人们、可调节的床、药品，我的迷你医院关闭了。我突然无事可做。我处于震惊之中。所以我打电话给珍妮，请她来陪我几天。
Joe Giese in Los Angeles.
洛杉矶的乔·吉斯。
[MUSIC- "SOMEONE TO WATCH OVER ME" BY RICKIE LEE JONES]
[音乐- 瑞奇·李·琼斯演唱的《有人守护我》]
Coming up, a marriage where they serve and protect. She serves, he protects. Or, maybe it's the other way around. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来，一个服务与保护并存的婚姻。她服务，他保护。或者，也许刚好相反。芝加哥公共广播和国际公共广播电台将在节目继续后的一分钟内为你带来。
It's This American Life , I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program of course, we choose a theme, bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，为你带来各种关于该主题的故事。
Today's program, "Someone to Watch Over Me," we have stories of three couples. In each story one person taking care of the other. We've arrived at act two of our program. Act Two, The Over-Protective Kind. Veronica Chater tells this story. The setting, the Bay Area suburbs. The characters, her own mother and father.
今天的节目，“有人守护我”，我们有三个夫妻的故事。在每个故事中，一个人照顾另一个人。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，过度保护型。维罗妮卡·查特讲述了这个故事。背景，湾区郊区。角色，她自己的母亲和父亲。
Recently, my parents' marriage went through a few weeks of chaos when my mom announced that she was taking a vacation. Turns out, Noreen, her best friend of 40 years, was inviting her to Puerta Vallarta, Mexico, to spend a week in her timeshare.
最近，我父母的婚姻经历了几周的混乱，当时我妈妈宣布她要休假。原来，她40年的闺蜜诺琳邀请她去墨西哥巴亚尔塔港，去她那度假公寓待一周。
My parents had been married for 45 years and they've never been apart for more than a day or two. What's more, in those 45 years, they've never taken a vacation. Partly because they've been raising 11 children and helping to raise 20 grandchildren. And partly because my dad's feelings about vacations go something like this.
我父母结婚45年了，从未分开超过一天或两天。更重要的是，在这45年里，他们从未去度假。部分原因是因为他们养育了11个孩子，并帮忙抚养了20个孙辈。部分原因是因为我父亲对度假的看法大概是这样的。
I detest shopping. I detest eating out. I detest motels. I detest beaches. I detest anything having to do with what most people go on vacations for. For me, it's the opposite of having fun. It's a purgatory.
我讨厌购物。我讨厌外出吃饭。我讨厌汽车旅馆。我讨厌海滩。我讨厌任何人们度假所追求的东西。对我来说，这和享受乐趣恰恰相反。这是一种炼狱。
Mom didn't even think of inviting him along. But as she began preparing for her trip, Dad began worrying. My dad is something of a safety net. He was a police officer and then a corporate security consultant. And as a result, he's the kind of guy who sees danger around every corner and is ready to defend himself and his family against any possible foe.
妈妈甚至没想过邀请他一起去。但当她开始为旅行做准备时，爸爸开始担忧了。我爸爸就像一个安全网。他曾是一名警察，后来担任企业安全顾问。因此，他是那种在每个角落都能看到危险，并随时准备防御任何可能敌人的家伙。
As I was growing up, whenever our birthdays came around, my brothers and sisters and I always knew the present from dad was going to be a weapon. A hunting knife say, or a rifle.
在我成长过程中，每当生日到来时，我和兄弟姐妹们总是知道爸爸的礼物会是某种武器。比如一把猎刀，或者一支步枪。
After I was the victim of a violent crime about 10 years ago, he only got worse. He took me out to buy a gun, a Colt 38 detective special, and taught me how to use it.
在大约10年前我成为暴力犯罪的受害者后，他变得更糟糕了。他带我去买了一把枪，柯尔特38侦探专用手枪，并教我如何使用。
Then he wrote a book called The Protection Formula : Thinking like a Cop , to teach ordinary people to be more like him. These days, when he bicycles to work each day on a busy road in the California suburbs, he carries with him a fully stocked survival kit. Ace bandages, iodine, insulating blanket, and just to be on the safe side, a 10-inch long bayonet. He'd carry a gun if he could, but as a former cop, he'd never dream of breaking California's concealed weapons law.
然后他写了一本书叫《保护公式：像警察一样思考》，教普通人如何变得像他一样。现在，当他每天骑自行车在加州郊区的一条繁忙道路上去上班时，他随身携带一个装备齐全的求生包。医用绷带、碘酒、隔热毯，为了安全起见，还有一把10英寸长的刺刀。如果可以的话他会随身带枪，但作为前警察，他绝不会想到违反加州的隐蔽武器法律。
Given all this, when my mom broke the news that she was heading on vacation to a foreign country, it meant only one thing to my dad-- peril.
鉴于这一切，当我妈妈宣布她要去国外度假时，对我爸爸来说只意味着一件事——险境。
You get two quite naive women down there and my wife still has sex appeal as far as I'm concerned ant that's a case for worry. It isn't only that she still has sex appeal, it's the fact that there are bad people that will do things to compromise a middle-aged woman. They might think she's wealthy. Who knows what a depraved person will think. You don't know, there's plenty of them out there.
两个相当天真的女人下到那里，而且就我而言，我妻子依然有性吸引力，这是一个令人担忧的理由。不仅是因为她依然有魅力，而且事实是，有坏人会做些事情来伤害一个中年女性。他们可能会觉得她很有钱。谁知道一个堕落的人会怎么想。你不知道，外面那种人多的是。
Do you think he's right to feel afraid?
你觉得他感到害怕是对的吗？
No, because of where we're going to be. When you're in a place like Puerta Vallarta, which is a resort town, and I've talked to several people that I've come in contact with that have been there, and it's been fine. And we're not that naive, my goodness sakes.
不，因为我们要去的地方。当你身处像巴亚尔塔港这样的地方，这是一个度假小镇，我接触过好几个去过那里的人，那里很好。我们没那么天真，天哪。
Do you really think Mom's being naive to say--
你真的觉得妈妈天真吗，说是——
Yes, I think she is. We've discussed this before. There's a state of mind that some people do not have. They don't have a vigilance about them. They don't suspect and that bothers me.
是的，我认为她是。我们以前讨论过这个问题。有些人缺乏某种心态。他们缺乏警惕性。他们不怀疑，这让我很烦。
Dad had plenty of ideas about what might happen to mom in Puerta Vallarta. Someone could slip a Mickey into her drink. They could copy her hotel room key and follow her back to her room. Dad stewed about this for two weeks, and then one day he announced to my mom that he had no choice, he was coming with her. It would be the only way to ensure her safety.
爸爸对妈妈在巴亚尔塔港可能发生的事情有很多想法。有人可能会往她饮料里下药。他们可能会复制她的酒店房门钥匙并跟回房间。爸爸为这件事愁了两周，然后有一天他宣布对我妈说，他没得选择，他得跟着去。这是确保她安全的唯一方法。
Mom was stunned and stammered that of course, he'd be welcome to come. And then she quickly called Noreen. This wasn't the vacation either of them had in mind and they had to do some last minute juggling. They had to figure out sleeping arrangements. They had to buy another plane ticket. And while Mom went about shopping for swimsuits and suntan lotion, Dad started preparing for the trip in his own way. By faxing a letter to the Mexican consulate asking which weapons of self defense he could legally bring into the country.
妈妈惊呆了，结结巴巴地说他当然受欢迎。然后她赶紧打电话给诺琳。这并不是她们俩心目中的度假方式，她们不得不做些临时的调整。她们得安排住宿。她们得买另一张机票。当妈妈去购买泳衣和防晒霜时，爸爸开始以自己的方式为旅行做准备。通过传真给墨西哥领事馆，询问他能合法带什么自卫武器入境。
I asked Dad to read a sample from the latter.
我让爸爸读了一封信的样本。
Presumably, guns are not allowed there for travelers, but what about pepper spray and knives? I'm retired from law enforcement and therefore I know intimately, our state laws on bladed weapons, which are very specific as to length of blade, concealed and et cetera. And because I want to stay within the law in Mexico, I'd like to know specifics. What is the language of the laws as to blade length, concealment, folders versus fixed blades, gravity knives, and so on. Also, the laws on pepper spray or the like. And a final question, if we decide to rent a car and drive in the hinterland, is it possible to hire protection? For instance, off duty policeman.
据推测，那里禁止旅客带枪，但胡椒喷雾和刀呢？我已从执法部门退休，因此我非常了解我们州关于刃具的法律，具体到刀刃长度、隐蔽性等等。而且因为我想在墨西哥遵守法律，我想了解细节。关于刀刃长度、隐蔽性、折叠刀对比固定刀、重力刀等的法律用语是什么。还有关于胡椒喷雾或类似物品的法律。最后一个问题，如果我们决定租车去偏远地区开车，有可能雇佣保护吗？例如，下班的警察。
Dad never did get a response to his letter. But he did hear from his law enforcement buddies that bringing a weapon into Mexico could land him in jail indefinitely. He began to worry that announcing his desire to enter the country armed might not have been the best way to introduce himself to the Mexican authorities.
爸爸从未收到回信。但他从执法界的好友那里听说，携带武器进入墨西哥可能会让他无限期入狱。他开始担心，宣布自己想武装入境可能不是向墨西哥当局介绍自己的最佳方式。
Meanwhile, my mom began worrying about how my dad was going to fare on the trip. He's a creature of habit with a nightly ritual that he follows religiously.
与此同时，我妈妈开始担心我爸爸在旅行中会怎么样。他是一个习惯的产物，有每天晚上严格遵守的仪式。
He comes in the kitchen, he has one shot of gin and he has a beer. And he's got his little hor d'oeurve there. He has certain things: radishes, carrots, onions, cheese. He's now into Gruyere. He likes the Gruyere. Then he sits down and has his meal. And then he has to go right to bed. That's it. And so there's no visiting. You don't do any-- I mean, he's got this thing. He does it. Every night, same thing. And he's so routinized it drives you crazy.
他走进厨房，喝一杯杜松子酒和一瓶啤酒。他有他的小点心。他有固定的东西：萝卜、胡萝卜、洋葱、奶酪。他现在喜欢格鲁耶尔奶酪。他喜欢格鲁耶尔。然后他坐下来吃顿饭。然后他就得马上睡觉。就是这样。没有访客。他不会做任何——我的意思是，他有这一套。他这样做。每天晚上，一模一样。他太循规蹈矩了，让人抓狂。
Does he watch a movie every night?
他每晚看电影吗？
Yeah, well not a movie. He never watches a movie. He's got six to eight pieces. He watches pieces of this, that, and the other. He's either looking for something and it a car that he saw, or there's a diner. Or there's a particular scene that reminds him of something. Or I don't know, he's just got his little-- yeah, all that stuff.
嗯，不是电影。他从不看电影。他有六到八个片段。他看这个、那个、其他的片段。他要么在找什么东西，是一辆他看到的车，或者是一家餐馆。或者有一个特定的场景提醒他什么事。或者我不知道，他就是有他的小——是的，所有这些东西。
For a week my dad vacillated on his decision to go. Finally, he told mom he'd decided to stay home, blaming his change of heart on back pain. Mom was secretly relieved. The night before she left, as Dad offered last minute instructions on how to jam the hotel door shut with a chair, she wrote out her flight details and gave Dad a list of household chores. The next morning, she was gone.
有一周，爸爸对去不去旅行一直犹豫不决。最后，他告诉妈妈他决定留在家，将自己的改变心意归咎于背痛。妈妈私下里松了一口气。她出发前的那晚，当爸爸提供最后时刻的说明如何用椅子堵住酒店门时，她写下了航班详情，并给爸爸列了一张家务清单。第二天早上，她走了。
Four days later, I dropped in to see how Dad's getting along. When I show up, the front door is locked. Something that never happens when Mom's around. I have to knock loudly twice. When he finally opens the door, Dad is unshaven. His white hair uncombed. All the windows are closed and the curtains shut.
四天后，我顺便来看看爸爸过得怎么样。当我出现时，前门锁着。这是妈妈在时从不会发生的事。我不得不大声敲门两次。当他终于打开门时，爸爸没刮胡子。白发也没梳。所有的窗户都关着，窗帘也拉上了。
Last night's video, Cast Away , sits on the TV set. I tell Dad he looks like he's the one who's stranded on a desert island. He pretends to find the joke funny, but he can't muster a smile.
昨晚的录影带，《荒岛余生》，正放在电视机上。我告诉爸爸他看起来像个被困在荒岛上的人。他假装觉得这个笑话很有趣，但他挤不出笑容。
OK, so we go 011.
好吧，我们就从011开始。
I suggest we call mom to check up on her.
我建议我们打电话给妈妈问候一下。
Well, we're just out. We cannot believe the humidity here, the heat. We've just had to stay in the hotel almost the whole time. It's dirty out there. Just dirty.
嗯，我们刚出来。我们简直不敢相信这里的湿度，这热度。我们几乎一直呆在酒店里。外面太脏了。简直脏死了。
You had to stay in the hotel?
你们一直呆在酒店里？
Yeah, we've just had to stay in here because we can't stand the heat.
是的，我们不得不一直呆在里面，因为我们受不了这热度。
Oh my gosh. Well, that makes me feel better.
天哪。嗯，这让我感觉好多了。
It makes you feel better?
这让你感觉好多了？
Yeah. I'm almost to the point of being in a full depression here with you being away.
是的。你离开后，我都快抑郁了。
Mom knows just the words that will get Dad's attention: heat, dirt, thieves, danger all around.
妈妈知道哪些话会引起爸爸的注意：热度、脏乱、小偷、四处潜伏的危险。
Well, we walked by some people and Noreen and I, we were just hanging on to our purses. We thought oh my gosh, Lyle was right. He should have come. For Pete's sake we're like, what are we in here? This is ridiculous. I don't know, but anyways.
嗯，我们走过一些人旁边，诺琳和我，我们紧紧抓住钱包。我们想天哪，莱尔说得对。他本该来的。看在上帝的份上，我们在想，我们待在这儿干嘛？这太荒唐了。我不知道，但总之。
Haven't you done any shopping or gone--
你们没去购物或者去——
How can you shop? You can't even breathe out there.
怎么购物？外面连呼吸都困难。
Dad leans back in his chair. He's beaming. He looks genuinely pleased that he was right about everything. That mom is stuck in her hotel room, having no fun at all. Finally, when she knows Dad is all worked up, she drops the bomb.
爸爸靠在椅子上。他满面春风。他看起来真心觉得在每一件事上他都是对的。妈妈被困在酒店房间里，一点乐趣也没有。最后，当她知道爸爸已经情绪激动时，她扔下了一枚炸弹。
OK, now you want the real scoop now? You ready?
好了，现在你想听真话吗？准备好了吗？
Yes.
是的。
OK, it's fabulous. Absolutely fabulous.
好了，太棒了。绝对太棒了。
Now I'm getting depressed again. I'm sorry, but I'm going to tell the truth here. Oh my gosh. In fact, we weren't here because we were laying by the pool.
现在我又开始抑郁了。抱歉，但我打算说实话。天哪。事实上，我们没在那儿，因为我们一直躺在泳池边。
The trip was just as they'd imagined it would be. No, better. The people were the friendliest she'd ever met. She and Noreen were buying tacos from street vendors, bartering with the local merchants, and attending mass in a Mexican church. You could hear in her voice that she was having the time of her life. And this was even before we saw the pictures of the young waiter pouring tequila and grenadine down her throat at dinner one night.
旅行就像她们想象的那样。不，更好。人们是她见过最友好的。她和诺琳从街头小贩那里买玉米饼，与当地商人讨价还价，并参加墨西哥教堂的弥撒。从她的声音就能听出她过着一生中最快乐的时光。甚至在我们看到年轻服务员在晚餐时往她喉咙里倒龙舌兰酒和红石榴糖浆的照片之前，她就已经是这样了。
As Mom goes on, Dad's face slowly sinks into a frown. He looks disappointed and confused. Not a single bad thing happened? It was all good? He waits for Mom's effervescence to run out of fizz. And when it doesn't, he jumps in at the first opportunity.
随着妈妈继续说下去，爸爸的脸慢慢皱了起来。他看起来既失望又困惑。没发生一件坏事？一切都很好？他等待妈妈的兴奋劲儿消退。当没消退时，他在第一时间插话了。
Let me interrupt. I couldn't find the freezer key.
让我打断一下。我找不到冷冻室的钥匙。
It's hanging above the washer. I showed you.
挂在洗衣机上面。我给你看过。
OK, I'll look. And I couldn't find your checkbook.
好吧，我去找找。而且我找不到你的支票簿。
Then, when Mom asks Dad how he's doing, he gives her all the grisly details of the lousy time he's been having in her absence.
然后，当妈妈问爸爸过得怎么样时，他告诉她他在她离开后度过的悲惨时光的所有细节。
Those packaged foods things you bought me are awful.
那些你买给我的包装食品简直太难吃了。
You're kidding?
你在开玩笑吧？
Our best meal since you've been gone has been Jack in the Box.
你走后我们吃得最好的一顿是Jack in the Box。
Did you put those in the oven?
你把那些放进烤箱了吗？
Yeah, I cooked them.
是的，我煮了。
Oven or the microwave?
烤箱还是微波炉？
In the microwave.
用微波炉。
No, oven is always better for those things.
不，烤箱做那些东西总是更好吃。
Well, it's too late.
嗯，太晚了。
Those are expensive. Those should be really good, Lyle.
那些很贵。那些应该很好吃才对，莱尔。
Well, they weren't.
嗯，并不好吃。
When Dad hangs up the phone, he sinks further into self pity. All these years he'd been living under the misconception that he was the one in charge. The man with the badge, worried and over-protetive, and laying down rules. But in fact, she is the one who takes care of him. Without Mom at home to look after him, Dad was defenseless.
当爸爸挂断电话，他进一步陷入了自怜。这些年来，他一直生活在一个误区中，以为自己是当家人。那个带着徽章的男人，忧心忡忡、过度保护，还定下规矩。但事实上，是她在照顾他。家里没有妈妈照顾他，爸爸简直手无寸铁。
I wanted her to go and have a good time I'm just nervous. I'm so used to having her presence here. It's incredible. It's physical. You can't see it coming. All of a sudden she's gone. She's not here. There's a different aura in the house.
我希望她去玩得开心，我只是很紧张。我已经习惯了她在这里的存在。这太不可思议了。这是实实在在的。你感觉不到它的到来。突然间她走了。她不在这里。屋子里弥漫着一种不同的气息。
What does the house feel like?
这房子感觉像什么？
Cold. She really is, she has a radiance about her. And she brightens things and it's gone.
冷的。她真的，她有一种光芒。她点亮了事物，但现在光芒不见了。
My mom survived the trip and my dad did too. And he even found his way to the right location at the airport to pick up Mom. True, he did arrive more than an hour late. Mom let him know she wasn't too happy about that. And once she got home she reprimanded him for being a hopeless housekeeper and a terrible gardener. But Mom could have scolded Dad all she like. He was enjoying every minute of it. You could see it in his face as she lined up the sliced radishes, counted out the correct number of olives, and made his salad just the way he likes it.
我妈妈幸存了下来，我爸爸也是。他甚至在机场找到了合适的位置去接妈妈。诚然，他确实晚了一个多小时。妈妈让他知道她对此不太高兴。她回家后训斥他是个没救的管家和糟糕的园丁。但妈妈想怎么责备爸爸都行。他享受其中的每一分钟。当她摆好切好的萝卜，数出正确数量的橄榄，并按照他喜欢的方式做沙拉时，你能从他的脸上看出来。
Veronica Chater in Northern California.
北加州的维罗妮卡·查特。
[MUSIC- "SOMEONE TO WATCH OVER ME" BY STING]
[音乐- 斯汀演唱的《有人守护我》]
Act Three, "Are You a Man or Are You a Mouse?"
第三幕，“你是男人还是胆小鬼？”
Well, we close our show with this story of a woman taking care of her man. Who, like the other men on today's program, is not always doing so well. Aimee Bender tells the story. A warning to listeners that she mentioned sex in here.
好吧，我们以这个关于女人照顾男人的故事来结束我们的节目。就像今天节目中的其他男人一样，他过得也不太好。艾米·本德讲述了这个故事。给听众一个警告，她在里面提到了性。
My lover is experiencing reverse evolution. I tell no one. I don't know how it happened, only that one day he was my lover and the next he was some kind of ape.
我的爱人正在经历反向进化。我没告诉任何人。我不知道是怎么发生的，只知道有一天他是我的爱人，第二天他变成了一种猿。
It's been a month and now he's a sea turtle. I keep him on the counter in a glass baking pan filled with salt water. Ben, I say to his small, protruding head, can you understand me? And he stares with eyes like little droplets of tar. And I drip tears into the pan, a sea of me.
已经一个月了，现在他是一只海龟。我把他养在柜台上的玻璃烤盘里，里面装满了盐水。我对那颗小小的、凸起的头说：本，你能听懂我的话吗？他用那双像焦油滴一样的眼睛盯着看。我把眼泪滴进盘子里，那是属于我的海。
He is shedding a million years a day. I'm no scientist, but this is roughly what I've figured out. I went to the old biology teacher at the community college and asked him for an approximate timeline of our evolution. He was irritated at first. He wanted money. I told him I'd be happy to pay and then he cheered up quite a bit.
他每天都在褪去一百万年的历史。我不是科学家，但这大致是我推算出来的。我去找社区学院的老生物老师，让他给我一个我们进化的近似时间表。起初他不耐烦。他想要钱。我告诉他我很乐意付钱，然后他高兴多了。
I can hardly read his timeline. He should have typed it. And it turns out to be wrong. According to him, the whole process should take about a year, but from the way things are going, I think we have less than a month left.
我几乎读不懂他的时间表。他本该打字的。而且结果证明它是错的。据他说，整个过程应该需要大约一年，但按照目前的情况来看，我认为我们只剩下不到一个月了。
At first, people called on the phone and asked me, where was Ben? Why wasn't he at work? Why did he miss his lunch date with those clients? His out of print special order book on civilization had arrived at the bookstore, would he please come pick it up? I told them he was sick, a strange sickness, and to please stop calling. The stranger thing was, they did. They stopped calling.
起初，人们打电话给我，问本在哪儿？他为什么不去上班？他为什么错过了与客户的午餐约会？他那本绝版的特别定制文明书已经到书店了，他能来取吗？我告诉他们他病了，一种奇怪的病，请不要再打电话了。更奇怪的是，他们真的照做了。他们停止了打电话。
After a week, the phone was silent and Ben, the baboon, sat in a corner by the window wrapped up in drapery chattering to himself.
一周后，电话安静下来，狒狒本坐在窗边的角落里，裹在窗帘里，独自叽叽喳喳。
The last day I saw him human he was sad about the world. This was not unusual, he was always sad about the world. It was a large reason why I loved him. We'd sit together and be sad and think about being sad and sometimes discussed sadness.
我见到他像人的最后一天，他为世界感到难过。这并不稀奇，他总是为世界感到难过。这也是我爱他的重要原因。我们会坐在一起，感到难过，思考难过，有时讨论难过。
On his last human day he said, Annie, don't you see? We're all getting too smart. Our brains are just getting bigger and bigger and the world dries up and dies when there's too much thought and not enough heart. He looked at me pointedly, blue eyes unwavering. Like us, Annie, he said. We think far too much.
在他做人的最后一天，他说：安妮，你没看到吗？我们都变得太聪明了。我们的大脑变得越来越大，当思想太多而内心太少时，世界就会干涸并死亡。他直截了当地看着我，蓝色的眼睛坚定不移。他说：像我们一样，安妮。我们想得太多了。
On his last human day, he put his head in his hands and sighed. And I stood up and kissed the entire back of his neck. Covered that flesh, made wishes there because I knew no woman had ever been so thorough, had ever kissed his every inch of skin. I coated him. What did I wish for? I wished for good. That's all. Just good.
在他做人的最后一天，他把头埋在手里叹了口气。我站起身来，亲吻了他整个脖子的后方。覆盖住那块肉，在那里许下愿望，因为我知道没有任何女人曾如此彻底地爱过他，亲吻过他每一寸皮肤。我包裹着他。我许了什么愿？我只愿他好。就是这样。仅仅是好。
I took him in my arms and made love to have, my sad man. See we're not thinking, I whispered into his ear while he kissed my neck. We're not thinking at all. And he pressed his head into my shoulder and help me tighter.
我把他抱在怀里，和我忧伤的男人做爱。我在他耳边轻声说：看，我们没有思考，我们完全没有思考。他把头抵在我的肩膀上，帮我抱得更紧。
Afterward, we went outside again. There was no moon and the night was dark. Then he told me he wanted to sleep outside for some reason. And in the morning, when I woke up in bed, I looked out to the patio and there was an ape sprawled on the cement. Great, furry arms covering his head to block out the glare of the sun.
之后，我们又去了外面。没有月亮，夜晚很黑。然后他告诉我，不知道为什么，他想在外面睡觉。第二天早上，当我醒来时，我看向露台，水泥地上趴着一只猿。巨大的毛茸茸的手臂遮住头，以挡住刺眼的阳光。
Even before I saw the eyes, I knew it was him. And once we were face to face, he gave me his same sad look. I sat with him outside and smoothed the fur on the back of his hand. When he reached for me, I said, no, loudly and he seemed to understand and pulled back. I have limits here.
甚至在我看到眼睛之前，我就知道是他。当我们面对面时，他给了我他那同样的忧郁表情。我坐在他外面，抚摸他手背上的毛。当他伸手向我时，我大声说：不。他似乎理解了，缩了回去。我在这里是有底线的。
We sat on the lawn together and ripped up the grass. I didn't miss human Ben right away, I wanted to meet the ape too. But I didn't realize he wasn't coming back.
我们坐在草地上，一起撕扯草地。我并没有立刻想念做人的本，我也想认识这只猿。但我没意识到他不会回来了。
Now, I come home from work and look for his regular size shape walking and worrying, and realize over and over that he's gone. I pace the halls. I chew whole packs of gum in mere minutes. I review my memories and make sure they're still intact. Because if he's not here, then it is my job to remember.
现在，我下班回家，寻找他那普通身材的走动和担忧，一遍又一遍地意识到他已经走了。我在大厅里踱步。我几分钟就嚼完一整包口香糖。我回顾我的记忆，确保它们依然完整。因为如果他不在这里，那么记住他就是我的工作。
I think of the way he wrapped his arms around my back and held me so tight it made me nervous. And the way his breath felt in my ear-- right.
我回想他用双臂搂住我的背，把我紧紧抱住以至于让我紧张的感觉。还有他在我耳边的呼吸——对。
When I go to the kitchen I peer in the glass and see he's some kind of salamander now. He's small. Ben, I whisper, do you remember me? Do you remember? His eyes roll up in his head and I dribble honey into the water. He used to love honey. He looks at it and then swims to the other end of the pan.
当我走进厨房，我透过玻璃往里看，看到他现在是一种蝾螈。他很小。我低声说：本，你记得我吗？你记得吗？他翻起白眼，我把蜂蜜滴进水里。他以前很爱蜂蜜。他看着蜂蜜，然后游向盘子的另一端。
This is the limit of my limits. Here it is. You don't ever know for sure where it is and then you bump up against it and bam, you're there. Because I cannot bear to look down into the water and not be able to find him at all. To search the tiny clear waves with a microscope lens and to locate my lover, the one-celled wonder, brainless, benign, heading clear and small like an eye floater into nothingness.
这是我的底线。就在这里。你永远不知道它确切在哪里，然后你撞上了它，砰，你就到了。因为我无法忍受看着水底却根本找不到他。用显微镜镜头搜索细小的清水波纹，试图定位我的爱人，那个单细胞的奇迹，无脑、良性、清澈而渺小，像个眼里的漂浮物一样消失在虚无中。
I put him in the passenger seat of the car and drive him to the beach. Walking down the sand I nod at people on towels, laying their bodies out to the sun and wishing.
我把他放在车的副驾驶座上，开车送他去海滩。走在沙滩上，我对毛巾上的人们点头，他们把身体摊在阳光下，许着愿。
At the water's edge I stoop down and place the whole pan on the tip of a baby wave. Ben, the salamander, swims out. I wave to the water with both arms, big enough for him to see if he looks back. I turn around and walked back to the car.
在水边，我弯下腰，把整个盘子放在一个小浪尖上。蝾螈本游了出来。我用双臂向水里挥手，大到如果他回头看就能看见。我转过身，走回车里。
Sometimes I think he'll wash up on shore, a naked man with a startled look who's been to history and back. I keep my eyes on the newspaper. I make sure my phone number is listed. I walk around the block at night in case he doesn't quite remember which house it is. I feed the birds outside and sometimes, before I put my one self to bed, I place my hands around my skull to see if it's growing and wonder what of any use, would fill it if it did.
有时我觉得他会冲刷上岸，一个带着惊恐表情的裸体男人，经历了历史又回来了。我盯着报纸。我确保我的电话号码挂在上面。我晚上在街区周围走，以防他不记得是哪栋房子。我在外面喂鸟，有时，在我一个人上床睡觉之前，我会用手包住我的头骨，看看它是否在生长，并想如果它长大了，会有什么用处，什么能填满它。
Aimee Bender. Her story "The Rememberer" appears in the book The Girl in the Flammable Skirt.
艾米·本德。她的故事“记忆者”收录在书《易燃裙子里的女孩》中。
[MUSIC- "SOMEONE TO WATCH OVER ME" BY AMERICAN DRAFT]
[音乐- 美国草案乐队演唱的《有人守护我》]
Well, that song performed for our show by the band American Draft. You can download an MP3 of what we believe is the world's only metal cover of this Gershwin classic at our web site, www.thisamericanlife.org. You can also listen to our programs for free there.
好吧，这是美国草案乐队为我们的节目表演的歌曲。你可以在我们的网站www.thisamericanlife.org下载我们认为是世界上唯一的这首格什温经典的金属翻唱版的MP3。你也可以在那里免费收听我们的节目。
Our program was produced today by Lisa Pollak and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, Wendy Dorr, Jane Feltes and Sarah Koenig. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Will [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
我们今天的节目由丽莎·波拉克和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格、黛安·库克、温迪·多尔、简·费尔特斯和莎拉·柯尼希参与。我们的资深制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴赫曼和威尔[听不清]提供制作帮助。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
You know you can download audio of our program at audible.com/thisamericanlife. They have public radio programs, bestselling books, even the New York Times all at audible.com.
你知道你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife下载我们节目的音频。他们有公共广播节目、畅销书，甚至纽约时报，都在audible.com上。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助鸣谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who listens to our program each week this way.
WBEZ管理监督托里·马拉蒂亚，他每周都这样收听我们的节目。
He's naked on the bed except for one strategically placed towel.
他赤身裸体躺在床上，只有一条精心放置的毛巾遮挡。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of this American life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多关于美国生活的故事回来。
PRI, Public Radio International.
国际公共广播电台，PRI。